I wanted to take the time to catch up on
the Dungeons and Dragons controversy
that I somehow completely missed but
caught windov
um because I saw somebody on Twitter say
something like oh the hate for this is
overplay make sure you don't abuse
employees and I was like what's happened
now
just a great way to find out about Muse
is hearing about Mass abuse um none of
which I have actually seen this is the
earliest article that I could find
though it does look like it's been
updated
um January 5th so that I get an accurate
timeline of events that's how we're
gonna start and then we'll go through
some of the changes that have happened
since this first new story came out so
the first one is from Gizmodo and says
Dungeons and Dragons new license
tightens its grip on competition and if
you never love to hear that from a
creative company you like Titan control
rarely do we find fans of that phrase so
the new Dungeons and Dragons open gaming
license a document which allows a vast
group of independent Publishers to use
the basic game rules created by d d
owner Wizards of the Coast significantly
restricts the kind of content allowed
and requires anyone making money under
the license to report their product to
Wizards of the Coast directly according
to an analysis of the leaked draft of
the document dated mid-December the
creation of the ogl version 1.0 which
was originally published in 2000 has
allowed a host of outside designers that
publishes both amateur and professional
to make new products for a game that
remains entirely owned by Hasbro
subsidiary Wizards of the Coast while
this Arrangement sometimes created
products that directly competed with
wotc Publications it also allowed the
game to flourish and grow thanks to the
resources created by The Wider DND
community and I think this is a very
interesting point again before we even
get further into the meat of this the
problem with that would be that wizard
of the coast is dramatically
underestimating how much human
creativity actually is important for
that game yes they've created a cement a
uh sorry being sick means I'm so bad
with words
Foundation obviously wizard that the
coast Dungeons and the dragons the
actual books create a foundation but the
thing that actually makes those
campaigns like critical role successful
is not actually DND
it's the people who do critical role and
I think it would be very naive of them
to think that d d deserves like a huge
cut of the money that they make it
allows humans to be creative and make
something cool together but that's what
what's actually holding it together the
glue is the humans not the game itself
which I think is a little bit different
for video games or a lot of the time
you're reacting to a video game you're
seeing a twitch stream and react to a
video game or a YouTube video and if the
games industry is not going to restrict
people uh which has again happened in a
couple of cases like Atlas Nintendo
tried to do something
um Nintendo still actually restricts a
lot of my YouTube videos all the time if
the games industry isn't going to do it
how on Earth is Wizards of the Coast
going to do it with Dungeons and Dragons
when the whole campaign is basically
user generated and written but is new in
ogl 1.1 a lot actually while the
original open gaming license is a
relatively short document coming in at
under 900 words a new draft of the ogl
1.1 which was provided to io9 by non-wtc
developer is over 9 000. next well it's
low IT addresses new technologies like
blockchain and nfts it also takes a
strong stance against bigoted content
explicitly stating the company May
terminate the agreement if third-party
creators published material that is
blatantly racist sexist homophobic
transphobic figured or otherwise
discriminatory which is not really
surprising usually brands have a clause
of what you can do with said brand I had
the same thing with them using my
likeness in cyberpunk
um that I was like you're using my face
brand uh I have to make sure that you're
not going to be able to do anything that
I would not agree with with this
character so that that is not surprising
to me at all that Brands get to protect
their brands that's a pretty common
thing and it's kind of surprising that
it wasn't like that previously to be
honest by ending the original ogl many
licensed Publishers will have to
completely overhaul their products and
distribution in order to comply with the
updated rules large Publishers who Focus
almost exclusively on products based on
the original ogl including Piezo Cobalt
press and green Ronin will be under
pressure to update their business model
incredibly fast it is basically just
ending the original ogl but again my
question is will these companies call
Will press screen Ronin have to
retroactively change that much or is it
just going forward so this is just the
first story this was the original new
story I believe from Linda um so heading
forwards from there we have another
article here from the guardian it's been
a tough week for Dungeons and Dragons
fans the Reigns were pulled in on users
who come up with their own storylines
and new characters creating Legions of
imaginary worlds that spin off of the
original Fantasy role-playing game
confirmed part of this is that it would
Grant Wizards of the Coast the ability
to make money off of these products
without paying the person who made it
and companies that make over 750 000
will have to start paying Hasbro a 25
cut of their earnings how on Earth would
you regulate that so first okay that is
saying that the decision from Hasbro
slash Woods is the coast is that anyone
who makes over 750
000 based on the Dungeons and Dragons
license has to pay Hasbro a 25 cut of
their earnings when they make over that
amount of money which is actually easily
defensible I don't agree with this but
if you were to make the defense it's not
a hard one to make it's like 750 000
that's probably not most people that is
a hell of a lot of money that these
companies are making from uh another
brand like that is something that I can
understand an executive arguing for
considering the amount of money and that
basically those are like full proper
businesses in a lot of cases probably
running using DND as a brand that's not
nothing and I know there was a quote
from an executive at Wizards of the
Coast or maybe it was Hasbro sorry not
long ago saying that he felt that uh
Dungeons and Dragons was under monetized
which I would say is almost definitely
true again I understand these positions
and how Executives came to them but
they're still horseshit and we'll get
into that I'm sure again I don't agree
with it but I fully understand a dude in
a suit being like this is you know how's
anyone gonna be mad I don't think they
would have expected the outrage to come
from this is what I'm trying to say so
we've got some quotes from Dungeons and
Dragons planes here I almost cried about
it two nights ago said Baron dirop who
is 36 and lives in Tennessee he's been
playing D D since he was nine years old
learning the ins and outs from all the
relatives who shared plans called
Adventures which map out a general
storyline for each game while some
Adventures are written by d d itself
many others are written by individual
dungeon Masters under the proposed
license these plans could soon be owned
by Hasbro this is the part that I am so
strongly incredibly extremely against
Dungeons and Dragons for what it is is
giving itself too much credit it's
awesome and very cool but again as I
said at the beginning of this rant the
creativity that comes from the
individual writers dungeon Masters
people who have to curate these skills
that could do so without any other
Foundation they do not actually need
Dungeons and Dragons to do it um uh very
very impressive and to monetize them is
just shitty uh in no small part because
of what Dungeons and Dragons
accomplishes for a lot of other people
like the people get into being
professional writers uh from their
experience in Dungeons and Dragons plus
acting
um we probably have like a not small
amount of game designers who came from
playing Dungeons and Dragons and then
making campaigns and making them
available to other people and I do think
that people who are creating these
things deserve to profit from them
independently of d d who is not creating
the campaigns that everybody's playing
like if you are making an individual
campaign as an individual that's
something that you still created um
using that Foundation I just think that
it's just a shitty thing to do and it
makes perfect sense that DND has
operated previously as something that's
like open source it should be open
source that's the nature of the game and
to move away from that seems like you
are just forgetting like the whole point
of DnD and what it exists for in the
first place monetize other stuff
monetize other stuff surrounding DND go
make the DND movie that looks pretty
good like you there are other smarter
ways to monetize Dungeons and Dragons
the one thing that you should not be
doing to this license is rubbing people
of creativity making people hesitate to
be creative with the license that is
just not understanding what d d is for
in the first place it just seems like a
really really really bad idea many
people are simply leaving the game all
together said William Earl a 28 year old
YouTuber whose videos largely focus on d
d culture he said he had canceled his
subscription to D Beyond has Hasbro's
digital game companion and would never
buy another wizard of the coast product
wow uh more than 66 000 fans sign an
open letter addressed to Hasbro d d
Beyond and Wizards of the Coast
expressing disgust at the proposed
changes they view the changes as nothing
but a money rush and an attempt to
squash Small Time creators who do not
pose a serious threat to Hasbro if
Wizards of the Coast is saying
that anything you create they can own at
any point in time and if you are a small
Creator who is looking for growth I
guess the problem is that at any point
in time you could have that rug pulled
out from under you so you could grow
with that brand and then just lose it
completely so they can take a Dean again
a d d campaign that exists on a YouTube
channel or a twitch stream
which
yes why would you really work to create
it outside of obviously you know the
persistent Community fun whatever but
people who are trying to make Brands out
of this it kind of becomes
um pretty pointless and you would almost
immediately want to go to a competitor
what a stupid stupid why what a stupid
thing to do
dude oh because what always gets me
about this including when video game
Publishers talk about it
is the amount of marketing that you get
from YouTube and twitch can't be
understated there are some games that
are hurt by Twitch streaming and YouTube
culture and it's very few it's games
like that Dragon cancer it's games that
are small short and extremely
um emotional story focused and usually
don't have as much of a focus on
gameplay mechanics it's such a small
amount to be like actually we've decided
that let's plays without games aren't
allowed is just completely
underestimating the value of those
things that they're basically
advertising for free that's exactly what
this is the more people watch DND
campaigns the more people want to get
into DND like the only reason that I
really even know D D exists is through
word of mouth and if you try to kill the
hype of that word of mouth will make it
negative PR you can't make any money
either why tank your own brand instead
of just pivoting to find different
things that can profit it just seems so
nuts of all the corn sorry said it feels
like an issue created because of
business people that are always worried
about
short time of quarterly numbers rather
than recognizing long-term profits
exactly and
we can all think that that's stupid
unintelligent whatever
um but that's just kind of the way the
corporate world Works in terms of you
have quarterly sales
targets that you need to hit right or
like quarterly sales earnings so they
kind of have to think in the short term
to then think in the long term
um that's not a fault of these
individual business owners and it I get
why each of us is sitting on the outside
can be like this is really stupid and I
still think it is really stupid but that
is also the reality of running a
multi-million dollar business that I
think most of us probably don't have the
expertise too to uh tackle to reckon
with Jay Cushing a dungeon master base
in New York who has played d d for over
a decade believes that D D's community
of nerds will find inventive ways to get
past any proposed licensing I think that
that is possible but also just
the problem
and the weirdest part of this is that
there's a movie coming out Dungeons and
Dragons is like extremely popular right
now allegedly reportedly is the right
word to use they're not allegedly magic
also being at an all-time high and just
celebrating 30 years
it's very odd that in theory
everything that Wizards of the Coast is
making right now is very successful
and yet the things that they are doing
in terms of the brand are very negative
um they are clearly trying very very
hard to make a lot of money very very
quickly
uh and I suspect if we look at any
company that's come before they're
trying to sell that would be my guess is
that they recognize that they've got
all of this hype right now they've got
this movie coming out the brand is
potentially at an all-time high
um and yet they are tanking their PR in
order to make quick cash again
that seems like an insane thing to do
from the outside all of us are like what
the [ __ ] are you doing this doesn't make
any sense for every single person who's
not involved in that company to be so
confused about it it sounds very much to
me like they are trying to sell or yes
like Hasbro is trying to sell them that
is my guess or
the alternative is Hasbro is doing
really poorly in terms of money and is
trying to use that particular brand to
pad them out uh uh while fans were still
digesting has first content restrictions
they were hit with the news that d d is
headed into the mainstream this week
Parent PLUS announced it will adapt d d
into an 8 episode live action series
penned by the DodgeBall filmmaker Ross
and Marshall Thurber I did not know that
so they are also aside from the movie
also doing an eight episode live action
series man so we have an update here
just an update at the end of the
Guardian shortly after the publication
of this piece D Beyond posted a
statement saying it was never out
did it say that uh it was never Our
intention to impact the vast majority of
the community the company is reversing
its position on the ogl to protect
educational and charitable campaigns
live streams and cosplay and other
content created by community members it
has also announced that the re-drafted
agreement would not include any royalty
structure or the license back provision
that some people were afraid was a means
for us to steal work which is what it
sounds like
um based on
the idea that the minute that you make
anything under the Dungeons and Dragons
IP they would automatically own it yeah
you're effectively stealing people's
whack because again d d is just the
framework the creativity has to belong
to people you can't take that from
people
you can't take a dungeon master spending
six months crafting a campaign from
people you cut you can't do that this is
the update on DnD beyond.com from DND
Beyond staff that says an update on the
open game license should I should I do
it in my um EA executive voice
when we initially conceived of revising
the ogl it was with three major goals in
mind first we wanted the ability to
prevent the use of d d content for being
included in hateful and discriminatory
products second we wanted to address
those attempting to use DND in web3
blockchain games and nfts by making
clear that ogl content is limited to
tabletop role-playing content like
campaigns modules and supplements and
third we wanted to ensure that the ogl
is for the content creator the home
Brewer the aspiring designer our players
and the community not major corporations
to use for their own commercial and
promotional purpose this part phrased
like that I can also understand but it
kind of doesn't make sense at the same
time
I can understand why you would say that
why you would say we want to make sure
that this license is helping the smaller
creators and isn't letting huge
companies come in use DND to make big
Brands and Tackle all of the competition
um
but was that a realistic concern ever
and also how would you just taking a 25
cut really prevent that you know
no in addition to language allowing us
to address discriminatory and hateful
contact and conduct and clarifying what
types of products the ogl covers our
drafts included royalty language
designed to apply to large corporations
attempting to use ogeo content which it
did it was never our intent to impact
the vast majority of the community then
you should have made a clause for that
however it's clear from the reaction
that we rolled a one it has become clear
that it is no longer possible to fully
achieve all three goals while still
staying true to our principles how did
that become clear after you wrote this
how did that not become clear beforehand
how who penned this [ __ ] thing
you know what I think that this sticks
to the principles of DnD by the way you
can't play it without giving us money
anymore
royalty structure it will also which I
guess you didn't [ __ ] need anyway did
you God God it's so
um it will also not include the license
back Provisions that some people were
afraid was a means for us to steal work
that thought never crossed our minds
under any new ogl you will own the
content you create we won't any language
we put down will be crystal clear and
unequivocal on that point the license
back language was intended to protect us
and our partners from creators who
incorrectly allege that we steal their
work simply because of coincidental
similarities as we continue to invest in
the game that we love and move forward
with Partnerships in film television and
digital games that risk is simply too
great to ignore the new odl will contain
Provisions to address that risk but we
will do it without a license back and
without suggesting we have rights to the
content you create your ideas and
Imagination are what makes this game
special and that belongs to you wow it's
almost like you understand D and D where
was this when you penned the original
quote-unquote draft you know a couple of
last thoughts first we won't be able to
release a new odeo today because we need
to make sure we get it right but it is
coming
I would just walk the whole thing back
to be honest clearly the original ogl is
working just fine if d d is currently at
its most popular and is selling more
than it ever has before and it's about
to go on and make a TV series and movies
our plan was always to solicit the input
of our community before any update to
the OTL the drafts you've seen were
attempting to do just that we all we
want to always Delight fans and create
experiences together that everyone loves
we realize we did not do that this time
and we are sorry for that our goal was
to get exactly the type of feedback on
which Provisions worked and which did
not uh which we ultimately got from you
uh any change this major could only have
been done well if we were willing to
take that feedback no matter how it was
provided so we are shut up shut up
you could have just asked for feedback
you didn't have to be like actually
getting roasted by all of you on Twitter
was great it was really happy about it
thank you for caring enough to let us
know what works and what doesn't what
you need and what scares you without
knowing that we can't do our part to
make the new ogl match our principles
yes you can you can absolutely make sure
the new ogl matches your principles by
understanding your own [ __ ]
principles you absolutely can do that
you don't need to be roasted on Twitter
to understand your own principles as a
company that is not a requirement
finally we'd appreciate the chance to
make this right
we love dnd's devoted players and the
creators who take them on so many
incredible Adventures we won't let you
down
hey
this is something so the
the Gizmodo article about cancel DB on
subscription forcing Hasbro's hands
licensees are pushing back despite any
hopes that all of this might flow over
well-known Publishers who have
previously used the ogl almost
exclusively in some cases such as kobold
press and mcdm I've already put out
statements saying that they will either
be moving away from all versions of the
ogl or explicitly offering up their own
gaming licenses for the core games which
is actually great one third-party
publisher told at Gizmodo that they had
expected a Wizards of the Coast to
update the ogl as seen in the league
documents but not until 2025 during the
full release of DnD one now many
third-party Publishers have moved up
their migration timeline following the
publicity disaster surrounding the the
leaked new Dungeons and Dragons ogl uh
wanna Wizards the coast biggest
competitors the independent publisher
Piezo owner of Pathfinder and starfinder
RPGs is currently speed heading a
campaign to create an open RPG creative
license orc that would be stewarded by a
non-profit Foundation that's awesome
other Publishers including cargo press
chaosium and legendary games have
committed to the effort this next piece
which is paiso President Jim Butler
reveals plans for a universal RPG
license which seems like another
positive response to this again we don't
technically know right now what Wizards
the coast is actually going to do it
sounds like they're walking negative
things back we'll see if that ends up
making the case
kind of up in the air still I imagine
they will
um or at least already have in a small
pot but another part of the response to
this is is paizo President Jim Butler
revealing plans for a universal RPG
license the open RPG creative license
orc will be created in order to support
the industry in conjunction with fans
and creators uh as fans waited for the
Hasbro owned company to respond to the
ongoing controversy over the Dungeons
and Dragons open game license paizo
announced it would be financially
supporting an initiative to establish a
new gaming license dubbed the open RPG
creative license which will be known as
the orc Piezo does not intend to keep
this license nor will any of its partner
presses who have agreed to support this
license instead paizo and its team are
seeding control to the Azora Law Group
whose co-founder worked on the ogl at
Wizards of the Coast and hope to
establish a non-profit to Steward the
orc which is such a good idea that's
awesome uh we sat down with paiso
President Jim Butler for an exclusive
interview about the impact of the ogl
and the part is involved in this new
license the age of the ogl is over the
time of the orc has come it only just
occurred to me that it's awk
wow
flu man you know it just does [ __ ] to
your brain okay
wow Jim Butler plays the president we
started moving in this direction years
ago with the development of the second
edition of the Pathfinder role-playing
game instead of basing that game on the
specific mechanical expressions of
Systems reference system reference
documents opened by the open gaming
license we started our new edition with
a blank slate decoupling our game
mechanics from the copyrighted materials
in the prior srds in order to chart A
New Path we published path by the second
edition under the ogl because the ogl
had for more than 20 years proven itself
to be a safe harbor for Publishers to
collaborate and build off the work of
one another which is something that I
wish the games industry would do more of
that is actually a very cool foundation
for uh thriving creative industry and
it's a fun with it more video games
don't do that uh we wanted to make sure
that everyone in the community would be
able to innovate off our designs the
media controversy surrounding was its
plans to change the ogl made it clear
that any Safe Harbor that might have
existed before was in Jeopardy we then
started discussing our options with
aritonies at Azora law and orc was born
the orc license is envisioned as a
broader framework along the lines of new
or Creative Commons in which companies
May independently deposit their own
system always I keep wanting to say
resource system reference documents in
that sense it is not tied to a single
system or small set of systems and
importantly is not owned by a single RPG
publisher there are already a number of
major companies signed up for the orc
license so it won't launch without
content and more importantly that
content will grow over time safe from
outside influences man I hope that this
is terrifying d d that like
Piezo compared to wizards the coast is
very small but I hope that they're
looking at this and being like oh these
people are taking all of their business
away from us like they basically got
industry canceled
they got like ttrpg canceled which I've
never seen happen before what kind of
Community are you looking for during
iterations a goal is to ensure that the
open RPG creative license is flexible
enough to cover all RPG types and to be
protected from any attempt to alter its
primary Mission and I think that that is
a very important part of this so the
thing that like
create the open license however you will
it could always go up in Flames if you
are also able to be bought by a company
who ends up wanting to monetize the [ __ ]
out of you right so their idea with
starting a non-profit to manage the orc
is a really good idea that's like having
an impartial third party come in
um to make sure that nothing is meddled
with and sure those are still in theory
susceptible to corruption there are
plenty of corrupt non-profits but it is
a step above what Wizards the coast has
done which is like you're owned by
Hasbro it's such a big company they have
so much money
um it was almost inevitable that this
would end up happening to be honest uh
whereas what their goal is here again
right the creative license however you
want it's more about who owns the
creative license I think that actually
impacts its longevity and how moral it
is likely to remain so I think it's
actually a very good thing to for them
to have considered from the Trump and it
does show good intent of course this is
also for paizo very good marketing for
them they have any further comments on
Wizards of the Coast's ogl update the
the open gaming license was meant to
benefit all game companies in the hobby
game Space
as the leader in that space wizard has
the largest network of players and
therefore is most positively benefited
by the ogl we're baffled by the business
rationale that drove the lito GL 1.1 and
the negative impact to the entire hobby
industry that its loss would create yeah
I mean companies would have to shut down
like they would have just bombed every
other creative partner like all of the
businesses and for what
what like for 25
you know it's baffling it's just really
strange
um to take the rights away from people
to stifle creativity to like bulldoze
the industry in this way somebody in the
room knew that this was wrong someone
knew that it's just that whoever was
above them making the most money was
like shut up I don't care
uh so I feel like the positive to come
out of this awk license that's great
that's a really really good idea I think
them needing to walk it back because
people canceled their DND Beyond
subscriptions is also awesome that they
have to listen to it obviously we're
still kind of waiting for wizards to
give us an update and see what the the
end of this is and maybe it will end up
being a kind of a nothing Burger
um but it does feel like a very I want
to say baffling decision but it's not
baffling we know exactly where this came
from and why money it makes sense it's
just it's more like it's infuriating
like
jeez at what cost you know